okay at the service week I swore I was
going to be more positive but then this
happens so I'm going to do a couple of
things here first i am going to
completely 180 my original objections to
this so if you look back at some of the
older videos where i've talked about
this project as opposed to the last
couple my original issue with this movie
is the issue I have with pretty much any
time an animated classic gets remade in
live action I feel it undermines the art
of animation and treats it as a
redheaded stepchild while live action
was brought in to be the real movie and
I hate that so originally my concern was
that was all that they were doing in
that they were going to in my view
undermine the original by doing that now
while I still don't enjoy that practice
and I will continue to refuse to see
Disney's live-action remakes of its
animated classics in this specific case
I now would have preferred if what I was
afraid of originally was what was
happening because if I remove my baggage
and my issues with when animated things
get remade in live-action a live-action
just version of the 90s anime film would
have been very cool and again if I sort
of step out of my own head I think more
people deserve to see that story and to
understand that's going to get just
their mind workin thinking about big
ideas the way that I got to seeing the
animated version there's no reason that
people just cuz they're not into anime
shouldn't get to experience that so you
know what I wish that's what this movie
was now but this trailer kind of shows
to me that's not what this movie is this
movie is something that it didn't even
occur to me was going to happen which
was how badly that we're going to
strip-mine and dumb down and go okay
talk about the dumbing down in the last
video I did and this and that was based
off nothing but a motion trailer that
was reemphasize in the they didn't save
your life they stole it line well
they've now gone beyond doubling down
they've like triple quadruple down on
this thing and this latest trailer
basically to me locks down that
they aren't making ghost in the shell
they are making the standard template
generic government agent is being used
by their own agency story that has been
done to death since the 90s and just
putting a ghost in the shell cyberpunk
Sheen over it there's all this emphasis
on she can't remember her back she can
only remember snippets of it they've got
bits of her confronting you know her
superiors and the villains whole thing
seems to be opening up her mind how
she's being used liked it was hmm you
know what I know this exact plot I saw
it in directed VHS not even
direct-to-dvd directed VHS 90s movies
that was literally shelves of my local
video store all of them had this plot
this is wrote generic person works for
the government but realizes they're
working for the bad guys plot that
everything that they are showing us in
terms of plot points indicates that and
is this movie this story the series the
manga which I've now finished as i'm
recording this all of it deserves better
than that generic crap that is made for
TB level junk and you don't save it by
making it look really cool and you know
what the movie still does look cool but
what made ghost in the shell amazing was
not just better look cool but it was
dealing with big ideas and philosophical
ideas and that she wasn't looking back
to her past that she lost you looking
forward to the future of what she was
becoming and that scared her much more
than how she might have changed from
what she used to be and that is what
made fans really latch on and grab pain
go wrong with this thing not the generic
they they're hiding your past from you
junk I am rapidly of reaching the point
where I I may not have it in me to go to
the theater to see this I had said that
I would I was planning to but I like I
said what they're doing what they appear
to be do and again I will reserve the
possibility that marketing is just going
to
the movie isn't actually like this and
the marketing is dumbing it down to make
it more probable to get busting feeds
and maybe the movie itself as much
heavier that is possible but i'm not
going to extend that as benefit of that
i'm going to assume that what they're
showing me is representative of the film
and if it is I don't want so I'm now
looking at the possibility of not going
to see this movie I might not I've
really reached a point in my life look I
love doing this video's I would like to
do more reviews I would like to do more
reviews of things as they first come out
but I don't make a living off this it's
not worth it to me rush outs or
something that I'm pretty sure I'm gonna
hate so I'm going to be keeping an eye
on the market i'm going to see if
there's something that I can grab on to
other than the visuals that will give me
a reason to go and see this and you know
what maybe if the reviews are go to us
if I hear from enough people who I know
personally whose opinions i trust that
it's good maybe that'll be enough to get
me in the seat but as it stands right
now by self of marketing and so that's
the latest foul mood that i have been
sent into thanks to the marketing for
ghost in the shell did you see the
latest trailer what did you think about
it whatever you thought drop something
down in the comment let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks give
Elizabeth Council of geese podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned